alright alright alright
bang-bang-bang what's going on guys
let's wait a few seconds here as people
come in and then I will start answering
some questions first off I want to
really cover there's a lot of
misconceptions and things that people
don't understand about the financial
crisis and kind of how this plays out
how it's played out over time in
previous financial crisis so I'm gonna
do my best to answer some of those
questions the most important thing is
people need to understand that there's
cycles or kind of stages of a financial
crisis and the most important thing that
we've seen over the last couple of weeks
is something called a liquidity crisis
and during a liquidity crisis basically
feared uncertainty rules the day and
when there's feeling fear and
uncertainty
every single person wants the security
of liquidity right what liquidity
basically means is they want US dollars
they want to have the ability to take
those US dollars make sure they can
weather the storm and then also buy
assets if they if they need to buy those
at any point as well and so during a
liquidity crisis essentially what
happens is anything that you own right
as a financial asset investment asset
etc anything that has a liquid market to
it whether it's stocks bonds other
currencies gold Bitcoin anything you
sell it and you saw it as fast as you
can you're less sensitive to the price
at which you sell it because you simply
want dollars and then you hold those
dollars and so we've seen that over the
last couple of weeks and I think a lot
of people have mistaken the liquidity
crisis for the actual financial crisis
but the liquidity crisis is simply the
start of the financial crisis we then
will enter into the actual crisis itself
where we see the domino effect or chain
reaction you'll see everything from
suppliers going out of business because
there's other businesses they can no
longer sell to you'll start to see all
of the real estate issues you'll start
to see public and private credit issues
you'll see the pensions that really come
under pressure that's where the true
financial crisis happens the simple
liquidity crisis isn't as bad
because it's just people looking for
liquidity so they saw everything they
can asset prices go down they get the
liquidity think of it as the dollar
strengthening and those asset prices
selling off so that's kind of a big
piece of this if you guys want ask your
questions in the comments here I'm gonna
do my best to get through a bunch of
them I'll hang out for about 45 minutes
or so so fire off those questions and
I'll get to them as I kind of in get
through this monologue here a little bit
but the other piece that I think people
are missing is there is a huge
disconnect between what's happening in
the public markets and what the reality
on the ground is right so there's been
this rally in the stock market and I
think a lot of people are saying why
their stocks going up but instead the
reality on the ground is that 16 million
Americans have filed for unemployment in
the last three weeks still you know 50
60 70 percent of small businesses in
America are shut down through a
government mandate and you and I are all
sitting at home and not allowed to go
out and so I think that what we're
seeing is a dislocation of the reality
and what's happening in the public
markets and so we just have to remember
that stocks can go down they'll recover
in these kind of relief rallies they can
go down even more there can be another
relief rally they can go down even more
and also they can go sideways for a long
period of time so don't get caught up in
Osaka recovering that must mean this
financial crisis is gonna recover
tomorrow
right there's still a lot of shelter in
place orders Virginia and DC etc that
are till June 10th right literally there
are states and territories are saying
people are not going to be able to leave
their home till June 10th and so that's
another 60 days away or so so I just
think that there's that dislocation or
separation between reality and what's
happening in the public markets and so
people need to be educated they need to
understand how this sequentially plays
out there's a liquidity crisis up front
everyone wants dollars asset prices sell
off the dollar gets stronger then you're
gonna see the intervention from the
government and what the intervention
really is is the government stepping in
saying we need to weaken the dollar and
the way that they weaken the dollars
they're gonna flood the market with
liquidity right they're gonna put as
many dollars in as they can around the
world other central banks will also
flood the financial system or the global
financial system with liquidity and what
that really does is that stabilizes
kind of the free fall of assets and then
ultimately over a long period of time or
medium period of time will reverse and
asset prices will start to recover and
so the reason why this is important to
understand is as the dollar is getting
stronger in the short term and asset
prices are selling off what will happen
is or that's called a deflationary
environment right the dollars literally
getting stronger it takes less dollars
to buy more of the same assets but that
will reverse and we will then head back
into an inflationary environment where
you'll get a reverse effect
we're basically now the dollar is going
to weaken and asset prices will rally
and so what really happens is when that
reversal happens the bottom 50% of
Americans get hurt and that's what I
want to spend some time talking about
tonight is how you can protect yourself
from that inflation because I think the
big problem right now is it's just an
education problem right people don't
understand how this occurs they don't
have like a very good understanding of
the sequence of events that will occur
and then they don't know what to do and
I'm not here to give necessarily
financial advice in terms of you know
hey buy this stock or do this but more
so just give you a framework of how I
think about it a number of other
investors think about it and what you at
home can do to protect your wealth
during these inflationary times so let
me see if I can jump on some of these
questions and then we'll get into into
the details as we go hey pop thanks for
all you do share your knowledge of
course I enjoy making all the videos so
happy - how to do it
what's my view on XRP I've pretty much
covered all the crypto stuff so I'm not
gonna get into too much crypto stuff can
I explain why stocks are going up as
unemployment as skyrocket yeah so this
is against what I'm talking about
there's this dislocation between what's
happening in the public markets right
investors are speculating that's what
happens in the in the stock market
investors are speculating on what's
gonna happen in the future and when they
see the announcement of all of the
stimulus they get excited the rich
people the people with assets in the
stock market they cheer right and they
get excited because they know if they
own stocks when liquidity floods the
market the dollar will weaken and stocks
will rally over a long period of time so
you see them buying into the stock
market
seeing that quantitative easing is
coming right or the printing of more
money the injection of liquidity the
second thing is there's a lot
speculation around when will there be a
cure or a vaccine for the virus right
there's a number of investors or a
percentage of the investor population
that believes once there is the ability
to come out of quarantine we will
essentially have what they call a
v-shape recovery rate there was this big
drop in economic output unemployment
skyrocketed but the second that we're
allowed out businesses will come back
online economic output will restart the
velocity of money will restart and those
people will go back to their jobs I
personally don't believe that's gonna
happen like that I just do not see the
American economy going from operating at
an all-time high kind of you know
absolute bull of all bull markets to
then going into this massive decrease in
economic output a complete stop of
velocity of money and a skyrocketing of
unemployment to then just go right back
to the bull market right I just don't
see that happening it's because if
anyone's ever run a business before you
know you can't simply be operating today
shut down tomorrow fire 80% of your
staff and tell your customers hey we're
shut down right now and then the next
day start your business back up higher
back 100 percent of your employees and
all of your customers come back it just
doesn't work that way and so I think
that we're in for a long road to
recovery and a lot of the speculation
that's going on in the stock market it
would not surprise me to see massive
sell offs when earnings are announced
over the next couple of weeks right and
really it's because again if you go back
and you look at something like a United
Airlines right United Airlines I think
last year did about six and a half
billion dollars in evena at some point
earlier this year was trading below six
billion dollars in market cap so 2019
even a six and a half billion 2020
current market cap was below six billion
you would say wow it's sold off from an
eighty eighty five dollar stock down to
20 25 bucks that's a steal but at in
reality if you look well what is
United's revenue going to be this
quarter right it's not gonna be
equivalent to a six and a half million
dollar or six and a half billion dollar
annualized EBIT a-- it's gonna be
something much lower and so in fact even
though the stock fell you know 60 bucks
it still may be overvalued given where
the company is today still has assets it
still has employees still has a business
but the revenue numbers are going to be
drastic
down and so if you go and you look at
something like the movie theater
industry right I think it's a third week
in March in 2019 the movie industry in
the US the domestic box office did about
two hundred million dollars in revenue
this year twelve months later it did
five thousand dollars so the way to one
way to look at that is literally if the
stocks of the physical movie theater
businesses fell ninety percent they
still would be overvalued if you compare
to the revenue which fell ninety nine
percent right so you can't simply just
say oh the stock prices followed bunch
of course that's a better value or a
value by top stock the second thing is
how many people are gonna run right back
into movie theaters and be cool with
sitting a bunch of munchy many strangers
and breathing the same air being in a
place where they're not sure did it get
cleaned did not get cleaned there's a
virus that still or may not be on the
loose etc so I just don't think that
it's gonna be this v-shape recovery and
so while the stocks are rallying and
unemployment skyrocketing I think that
really just signals that there's this
massive dislocation and it wouldn't
surprise me to see another massive
sell-off as people realize hey the
reality on the ground doesn't reflect
the way that we're currently allocating
capital and that's the beauty of markets
is markets are the ultimate referee
right they will eventually find
equilibrium if people don't manipulate
them if the government stays out etc so
I think that'll be really good to to
kind of watch would you buy silver or
gold stocks again I'm not gonna sit here
and kind of pick stocks or do anything
like that uh first of all I don't enjoy
doing that second I don't think I have
any advantage over anybody else but more
so I want to kind of share the framework
as how I think about this and so talking
about silver and gold and I'd also put
Bitcoin and real estate in this category
is these assets act as inflation hedges
and what I mean by that is right now in
a deflationary environment dollar are
getting stronger asset prices selling
off the government's gonna have to flood
the market with liquidity right over the
central banks well they're doing it all
around the world in the US we now have
trillions of dollars already announced
there will be more and so what I think
ends up occurring is that we will switch
back into the inflationary environment
when that occurs investors will seek
inflation hedge assets silver gold real
estate Bitcoin etc will all be
that they look for because again the
currency is gonna go down in value
compared to the asset so in January of
2020 let's say it took a hundred dollars
to buy a bar of gold or a piece of real
estate now in a deflationary environment
actually what happens is I can only
spend $80 I can buy that same bar of
gold or that same piece of real estate
so it takes less dollars to buy the same
real asset but when I go back into an
inflationary environment it'll go from
80 dollars back to a hundred eventually
to 110 120 130 dollars so over a long
period of time it will actually take
more dollars to buy the same asset than
it previously did and the reason why
investors will run out of the dollar and
into these assets is because those
assets are going to appreciate in price
and u.s. dollar terms and so things like
silver gold Bitcoin and real estate will
all benefit from let's take a shot each
time comp says liquidity I'm not
touching any of the drinking games you
guys you guys are the experts on that
you want what other people want if other
people want dollars then you want
dollars there's a really good point so
Jeff brings up a point about you most
investors are gonna want what other
people want right that is true to a
degree but over a long period of time
actually what you're gonna want is you
actually want what other people are
about to write so it's a nuance but it's
important nuance meaning that if
everyone wants dollars right now and
you've got a lot of dollars right before
they're gonna want the real estate of a
Bitcoin or the gold or the stocks or the
Treasuries or whatever the next asset
they're gonna want is you actually would
want to then go into those assets right
before everybody else right you want to
buy it when it's unpopular right before
it becomes popular now part of the risk
of investing is you got to pick the
right asset you got to pick the right
time etc and so timing the switch from
the deflationary environment to the
inflationary environment provides
opportunity but it also provides risk
and so people need to understand the
risk that they're taking but that is
part of the opportunity here and so what
I think you're gonna see is Apple right
all-time high levels of cash Warren
Buffett all-time levels in cash right
off like one hundred twenty hundred
thirty billion dollars in cash what
they've done is they basically hoarded
cash before everyone wanted it so they
foresaw that there was going to be a
deflate
shanira environment they held their cash
now everyone wants cash they have the
cash he who has cash during a liquidity
crisis makes the rules and that's what
we're seeing right now so all of a
sudden when we go right before we switch
my deflationary environment to an
inflationary environment you're gonna
see Apple Warren Buffett other people
who have big hoards of cash they're
gonna deploy that cash they're gonna buy
up assets at the low values that they've
crashed to and then all the inflationary
aspects will hit those asset prices will
rise and those that are then holding the
assets will actually benefit and so it's
not kind of a black and white take one
strategy and do this forever you also
have to understand the cycles or the
sequence of events during a crisis and
you've always got to be one step ahead
of the masses because that's how you buy
the asset that everyone's about to want
right I've got a partner mark uske who
he says Cubans are really good at to
doing two things they basically buy the
asset that they should have bought and
they sell the asset that they're about
to need which means that they basically
follow the herd right once they see that
stocks have rallied 300% then they buy
into stocks but they should have bought
it before rally three hundred percent
duh if they had a crystal ball they
would have done that right but then what
happens is when the stock market crashes
then everyone sells right and they sell
what they're about to need and so in
stock market crashes like he did in a
deflationary environment what happens is
there's little quiddity injection in
stocks rally say literally just sold the
asset that they would that they're gonna
wish in the future they would have
bought so kind of staying one step ahead
is really important in those
environments I've been watching 80% of
your interviews and I'm still poor
I appreciate the the laughs there let's
see Tom how do you feel about tether
with how much printing they've been
doing lately do you think it could end
up hurting Bitcoin somehow so okay so on
the Bitcoin front basically what I'm
gonna say here's I'm not worried at all
about tether I know that there's a lot
of people who are I'm just not one of
those people and then on the more macro
environment the way that I think about
bitcoins prospects moving forward
essentially is we've had interest rates
dropped to zero we've got tons of
quantitative easing happening or
printing of money both in the United
States and globally and right as
the effects of that stuff starts to take
place that switch from the deflationary
environment to an inflationary
environment we're going to have a supply
shock right and the reason why the
supply shock is important is right when
everyone turns to the inflation hedge
assets bitcoins incoming daily supply is
gonna drop 50 percent from 1800 Bitcoin
a day to 900 Bitcoin a day and so right
when that supply shot happens you also
will have a demand shock right supply
will go down our incoming daily supply
will go down the demand for Bitcoin gold
real estate etc inflation hedge assets
will go up and so you get this kind of
double move where supply goes in the
favor of a higher Bitcoin price and
demand goes in the favor of a higher
Bitcoin price and all of that happens
simultaneously and therefore I think it
will lead to a very large increase in
the Bitcoin US dollar value over the
next 18 months or so so again there's
risk in that and it's important that
people kind of do their own research
they understand how to size the risk
appropriately in their portfolio I for
sure I'm not telling people hey go take
a hundred percent of your assets and go
buy inflation hedge assets part of
protecting your wealth during a
financial crisis like this is making
sure you have enough liquidity to
weather the storm so I continue to ask
people do you have three months of cash
6 months 12 months 18 months how long
can you last as an individual a family
or a business with no income or no
revenues right kind of zero revenue run
rate and the sad part is a lot of people
can't last that long right and that's
where you get things like the payroll
protection program unemployment right
all of these programs that have been put
in place to try to help people but
ultimately the people that are going to
benefit the most going through this
period or the people who already did the
hard work right they already did the
disciplined unpopular hard thing they
didn't get overextended they didn't get
over leveraged they conserved cash right
they did all of these things and now
they're in a position to thrive coming
out of a financial crisis most people
are not in that position most people are
actually gonna be in the position where
they're going to have to do their best
to try to conserve cash now we're gonna
sell assets they're gonna do whatever
they can to get that liquidity so that
they have the liquidity to actually
weather the storm so step one is never
run out of money right whether you're a
business or an individual or a family
and so people
to understand this isn't gonna be a 2 3
4 week thing right this is going to be a
long-term financial crisis not just the
actual crisis itself but the recovery
and so what I continue to tell people is
make sure you have cash to weather the
storm 3 6 9 12 18 months however much
you can get make sure you have it and
then understand as we start to recover
you're gonna want to own some of those
real assets and benefit from that price
appreciation of the time do I think
we'll have a second dump in the S&P 500
again I don't know or think I have an
advantage in timing the market I don't
think that I've got some special skill
of picking stocks but I do believe that
there's a dislocation between what
public market investors are doing and
the reality on the ground there's a
whole bunch of reasons why but I also
think that the moment that is upcoming
where we're gonna see some earnings
reports I think is gonna scare people
right I mean who's ready to see a movie
theater business or a corporate
commercial real estate ETF right these
people report 99 percent loss in revenue
I just don't think people are pricing
that type of stuff into the market and
so we're gonna see what those earnings
reports look like but I think that they
will be worse than people expect which i
think is going to cause some panic in
the market and we'll see kind of what
happens there do I use technical
analysis no I use no technical analysis
I don't do any trading I am much more of
kind of an asset allocation type
investor so I basically look
structurally at markets I look over long
time horizon so anything that I buy I
hold over a medium to a long term
there's no day trading going on as
though tickle analysis price targets
anything like that button for my
investment decisions and right now it's
a couple people asking kind of how I'm
currently allocated I've got a big coin
is a big percentage of my portfolio I've
got some real estate I've got some
illiquid investments in the startup in
venture capital space and then I've got
cash right and that's kind of how I'm
currently allocated I don't invest in
public markets for a whole bunch of
reasons and so I also don't own any gold
oil anything like that and so it's
pretty much Bitcoin cash real estate and
some private investments in the startup
for venture capital space how where to
buy bonds and gains from asset
dropsy I'm not an expert when it comes
to buying the bonds there's people like
Raul call a real vision etc that are
much more well-versed in that and can
kind of give you exact execution tips
there what I will say is I don't think
that we've seen the actual bankruptcies
yet so again going back to this sequence
of a financial crisis you get the
liquidity crisis first then you get
these relief rallies then you get the
quantitative easing and the switch to
the inflationary environment and then
you get the recovery during that first
half is where you get the pain but you
actually don't see a lot of the
bankruptcies immediately remember this
financial crisis is four to five weeks
maximum in the life cycle right so we're
only four to five weeks in this would be
like the first four to five weeks in
2008 we knew that we were headed for
trouble but we didn't actually see the
really gnarly like kind of blood in the
street stuff but for a couple of months
and so I think the people would have to
be patient understand that there are
going to be a sequence of events that
play out don't evaluate the the severity
of a financial crisis simply in the
first you know three four or five weeks
I think you've really got to understand
the reality on the ground
the reality is 16 million Americans have
applied for unemployment the last three
weeks those are the people who
successfully did it that doesn't include
gig economy workers freelancers
self-employed it also doesn't include
some people on furlough doesn't include
people who can't get through right the
log jam etc and so right now at a
minimum there's 21 million Americans
unemployed my guess is that it's
actually much higher than that and we've
got 70 to 80 percent of small businesses
in America that are shut down through a
government mandate I just don't see us
recovering anytime soon so kind of be
patient I think is a big part of this
how deep do I think the second leg in
the downturn is going to be for SMP and
Bitcoin so I saw a really interesting
analysis at obby Costa how many of you
guys know him but but you should go
follow him on Twitter if you don't he
does a lot of macro and then gold and
some commodities analysis and he posted
a chart where he basically showed during
the Great Depression there was a very
steep decline on poke market there was a
25 30 percent relief rally I I believe
it was and then there was again another
like 25 30 percent down don't hold me or
on the exact numbers but basically what
it looked like was there is this drop
there was a recovery and there was a
second drop and and when he lined it up
it looks very similar to now now again
history doesn't have to necessarily
repeat itself but it definitely rhymes
and I think that we are likely to see
that right this is all a game of
probability there's no absolutes here so
knowing anyone who tells you for sure
we're gonna see another low they're
lying or or their or they're confused or
they're tricking themselves right but
also anyone who says well we definitely
won't see another low again they're
lying they're confused or they're
tricking themselves and so I think it's
a game of probability and if you said to
me you have to choose a side I think it
is more probable that we will see lows
in the public markets and other assets
it's more probable to see that than we
will see the full recovery and so I
think people just need to kind of
understand the game of probability
understand the risk reward there but
don't be surprised if we do see that
that fall and public equities pull from
the earnings reports that will come out
but also just kind of the nature of the
market or the market structure let's see
here what do when do you expect the
inflation for USD to start again really
really hard to kind of nail down exact
timing I again I'm not a traitor so I
don't look at like it hey on this day
we're gonna see the dollar weakened and
there from there short things plan is
cooking dinner and I think that she just
broke everything that's fine but in
terms of the US dollar I think that we
will see inflation obviously we'll move
from the deflationary environment into
an inflationary environment I expect
that to happen over the next kind of 12
months really it's gonna come down to
how much money do they print right the
first to that two trillion dollar
stimulus package I don't think is nearly
enough I have said kind of from the
beginning at least five trillion dollars
I think is what they're gonna have to
use to flood the market betcha
I'm the world staying liquidity tomorrow
past almost a trillion dollar plan many
other central banks are announcing big
stimulus packages and so we're gonna see
trillions of dollars that's kind of
injected into the global financial
system and all of that capital is going
to be needed in order to move from a
deflationary environment into an
inflationary environment again exact
timing I'm not gonna you know sit here
make any predictions but I do think
it'll happen over the next 12 months and
if you kind of position yourself
correctly both with hey I've got enough
cash to weather the storm and I
understand when we move into that
inflationary environment the real assets
or inflation hedge assets are gonna do
well then I think you'll be set up
really well over a long period of time
so we'll see there the public market
dissonance is real is there any credence
to the v-shaped recovery theory again I
mentioned this a little bit I don't
think that there's gonna be a v-shaped
recovery the way I tend to think about
this is I see a lot of people because it
is a V or two you right I tend to think
that it's something in between a U N and
L right the reason why I say that is you
basically get this big drop and then you
kind of get this grinding up of the
recovery and it's because again this
stuff takes time right if you think of
the velocity of money right or what I
call it the economic circle of life we
basically took that economic circle of
life we're suppliers go to manufacturers
manufacturers create products they give
them to businesses businesses so that
consumers businesses then pay rent to
landlords landlords then pay their
mortgages to banks banks help finance
and you kind of get this circular aspect
of the economy we basically came in
across the world and governments
mandated businesses shut down and they
go home and so when that happens you
break the circle of life right and you
get an upstream kind of stoppage think
of it as a dam in a river if the
businesses aren't selling their products
all of a sudden the suppliers or the
manufacturers don't have anybody to sell
to so they're now holding inventory if
they're holding inventory they're not
making more orders to suppliers and
somehow suppliers are screwed right they
can't pay their financing etc so kind of
a dam occurs and like in a river and you
get this upstream impact the downstream
impact is if the business has no revenue
how does the business pay their
landlords right so now you start talking
about rent abatement deferrals
forbearance etc and then if the
landlord's
not getting paid how do they pay for
their mortgage right and the problem is
that that chain reaction that domino
effect both upstream and downstream can
have material impact because what
ultimately occurs is at any point if
somebody is not given relief and that
relief can come in the form of the bank
tells the landlord hey will defer will
give you forbearance abatements etc you
don't have to pay us on time or as much
at cetera or government assistance
doesn't step in all of a sudden you get
solvency issues how is that landlord
gonna be solvent they have no revenue
coming in and they have bills to pay
what were they gonna do they're gonna
seek bankruptcy protection right same
thing with a bank if the bank doesn't
actually have any sort of revenue coming
in but they need the capital they may
have solvency issues right and same
thing with businesses that's why she the
government rush in and provide all this
assistance and so I think what you get
right now is you get a break in economic
circle of life if that break is for one
week or two weeks and people probably
have cash reserves they can kind of get
by I think a lot of people realize this
is gonna be multiple months type impact
and therefore what you start to get to
is if there is not assistance or relief
you will get solvency concerns and so I
think that's what people are really
looking at and we won't see that
v-shaped recovery let's see the US has
exorbitant privilege to print its own
currency courtesy of his global power
the world relies on the US dollar to
trade
absolutely the US dollar is relied on to
trade around the world but again don't
forget that one of the big things here
is the u.s. is not the only economy or
central bank that's printing money
everyone else in the world is also
injecting liquidity or printing money
into the their economies and into the
global financial system and so one way
to think about this is let's say that
the u.s. increased their quantitative
easing to X right that they started
printing two times as much money but
everyone else did to X as well well
actually it the impact on a
country-by-country basis you everyone to
X at the same time so you would keep the
same kind of strength relative to other
currencies the problem becomes if the US
prints three four five six times as much
as other economies or other currencies
then all of a sudden the dollar is
getting devalued at a faster rate so
you've got to really keep the relative
argument in the in mind here Brent
Johnson at Santiago
capitols got a great theory because the
dollar milkshake theory I had them on
the podcast and did a great job
articulating it and especially the
dollar milkshake theory is that every
central bank in the world is injecting
liquidity into the global financial
system so whether you're the United
States you're China York India you're an
African country South America UK where
ever right everyone is going to inject
liquidity in but there's only one
currency or economy that gets to hold
the straw right all the capital being
injected is making a milkshake but one
economy gets the straw they gotta suck
all the value out of the global
financial system and his theory is that
the dollar the US dollar will be the one
who holds the straw right and we're
seeing that right now all of that
liquidity is flowing to the US dollar
and seeing the dollar strengthened asset
prices sell off because everyone around
the world wants dollars what I foresee
happening is those that don't have
access to dollars for whatever reason
it's dangerous it's not a lot buy their
country etc they will then seek gold or
Bitcoin because that's the next best
thing
right the dollar is stable the dollar is
actually strengthening the dollar has
kind of the promise of the US government
it's got a track record but if you can't
get dollars then you're gonna look for a
gold or Bitcoin and so I think that's
kind of what's happening with the dollar
and the printing in the in the US and
then also how it relates to other
countries if in situations like this
where the Fed is printing and it creates
inflation with stocks and all these
assets go up anyways again I think I
covered that so I'll skip over that
let's see you're not gonna see any
inflation while 20 million people don't
have jobs I think it's a great point
right so again that's why I say kind of
there's like this 12 month window where
I think it'll take some time before we
actually switch from a deflationary
environment to an inflationary
environment but definitely for right now
when you've got you know 20 plus million
people unemployed now you got asset
prices selling off in the dollar
strengthening I don't think that that
trend gets reversed until you one get
people back to work until you flood the
market with with dollars or other fiat
currencies and so that's when I think
people will really start to realize you
know how that happens can I explain how
the Fed is bailing out hedge funds yeah
one way to think about kind of how the
Fed is bailing out hedge
very over-generalized manner without
getting into kind of all the exotic or
nuanced aspects is think about what
hedge funds do they hold assets but they
have high leverage there's many hedge
funds that are five seven eight ten
you know sometimes 20 times levered and
so what that ends up happening is when
you've got a bunch of leverage and these
markets get margin calls right asset
prices start to sell off they get margin
called in and they're told hey give us
give us more money either post more
collateral or you got to give us the
asset and so in those situations what
occurs is the Fed steps in it provides
liquidity to the market and it's trying
to provide relief they think of kind of
the bailout as it's relieving the
pressure on those hedge funds that
otherwise would have margin calls that
they can't meet exception we've actually
seen a couple of asset management firms
or kind of market makers step up and
kind of raise their hands to hey we
couldn't meet our margin culture I think
there was one in Chicago I think there's
been two or three others so that that's
kind of how that happens there's an
argument to be made that that's
important to do in order to preserve the
integrity of the markets or kind of the
sustainability of the markets on a
global scale because a lot of these
hedge funds are holding certain assets
that if all of a sudden they were had
had to sell and kind of a fire sale and
sell everything there would be a
tailspin or kind of downward death
spiral of asset prices I personally
think that you've got to let the free
market kind of operate here and if a
hedge fund got over leveraged and they
can't meet their capital call or their
margin calls why should anyone bail them
out right they're professional investors
they understand the risk they take of
yes there will be short term pain yes
people will get hurt but that ultimately
maybe those people shouldn't be managing
capital maybe those people shouldn't be
the ones who are actually doing this
anymore so what happens is in those
market Corrections or downturns you
clean out the people who aren't good at
their jobs right that's ultimately
what's happening here what do you think
to save Airlines by us and neglecting
unemployment again I you know people I
think I've come to realize I mean I'm in
the same camp as Mark Cuban shamov et
cetera I think he let him fail right and
that sounds really bad but at the end of
the day what's happening is the Airlines
Boeing you know all these companies that
are running to the US government for
bail
they believe that the government is the
idiot in the room and what I mean by
that is what essentially has happened is
let's again go back to let's use a
Boeing or United Airlines etc so United
Airlines I think spent over 80% of their
free cash flow for the last decade on
stock buybacks there's absolutely
nothing wrong with stock buybacks right
it's simply returning value to
shareholders and a tax efficient manner
that's perfectly fine but they've done
that for a decade with 80 percent of
their free cash flow and the reason why
they're doing that is because a lot of
the executive compensation is tied to
the stock price right the stock
performance and so if your compensation
as a CEO CFO etc is tied to the stock
price of course you have a stock price
to go up how can you get the stock price
to go up well you take free cash flow
and you buy back your stocks so that you
can prop up the stock price and then you
also put more debt on the company use
that capital that you raised in the debt
markets to then buy back your spot kind
of a debt fueled stock buy back again to
prop up the price because you're getting
more compensation for doing that so the
personal incentive is to do this right
now again perfectly fine
that's the incentives of the board of
directors put into examined compensation
that is how the structure works and that
is actually what these companies did now
the problem comes that the number one
rule of businesses never run out of
money and so what has happened is
they've taken all that free cash flow
that you normally would either sit on
their balance sheet or they would have
invested in R&D and they've given it
back to shareholders but now we come
into a situation where their revenue
falls off a cliff right and so they need
capital to survive they need to continue
to pay all their expenses their
employees etc but they don't have enough
capital on the balance sheet so they've
got to do one of three things or really
two things they can go to the debt
markets or the equity markets but when
they go and they check the debt and
equity markets they go to investors and
they say hey we need to raise capital to
get capital on our balance sheet so we
can continue to ride out this strong the
weather this storm the equity markets
and the debt market investors say great
I would love to invest in your business
or I would love to lend to you but the
debt investors say but I want a really
high interest rate on this because it's
super risky I don't know if you're gonna
make it and the executives look and they
say yeah that sounds too too high I
don't like those terms I'm not gonna do
that so then they go to the equity
investors and they
say hey we want you to invest in our
business and it equity investor said
great I'd love to do that I think your
business is worth one tenth of what you
think it's worth and of course the
executives say no I think our company's
worth more so they don't like the tums
that they're getting in the debt or the
equity markets but remember how markets
work there's a buyer and a seller and
the way a market gets made is that the
buyer and the sellers have to eventually
agree on what the value of the asset is
the difference here is that the
executives are pulling an ace of spades
out of their back pocket right they're
saying wait a second I actually have a
third option I don't have to go to
traditional dinner equity markets I'm
gonna go find the idiot in the room
who's the dummy who will give me
advantageous terms oh the US government
so they then turn to the government and
they say you need to bail us out it's
imperative for the airline industry to
survive you can't let us fail we are too
big to fail if you let us fail look at
how bad this will be and so what the
reason why they do that is not because
they can't find capital elsewhere people
in the debt markets and the equity
markets wouldn't give them capital but
it's at on the advent ages terms or not
attractive terms so they go to the
government and they say to the
government you've got to give it to us
and you saw like the Boeing CEO he goes
on television and he says we'll take
this the the bailout money but they're
not getting equity well the reason why
he's saying that is because every single
other debt investor that he's talked to
says I'll lend you money but it's gonna
be out of high interest rate and I want
Warren so I want equity in your business
but he doesn't want to do that so he
goes and finds what he believes to be
the dummy in the room and so if you look
up like one more Cuban saying more
Cubans essentially saying look you have
to get equity you have to get just as
good of a deal for the American taxpayer
as the private investor would get so
whatever those market rates are on
interest rate evaluation of the business
etc the US government has to negotiate
just as hard to get this same deal it
has to get a great deal right
why United Airlines other airlines other
companies looking for bailouts they are
not what we call price makers they are
price takers and what that means is when
you're in charge when you have all the
leverage in a negotiation right in the
good times companies there's lots of
capital that wants to invest in good
businesses the good business is going to
name their price they go to the investor
and say I want to raise X dollars at Y
right I'm a price maker I make the price
and the investor says yes or no if they
say no there's another investor that
will invest on those terms I get to be a
price maker now the rules have reversed
the companies are price takers now they
don't have to leverage the investors
have to leverage and the investors are
going to take advantage of it that's how
capitalism works that's how free markets
work so investors are saying I want to
invest at a lower valuation I want to
invest with a higher rate of return I
want to invest with both lend you money
and take equity in your business because
now the company and the executives are
price takers they're saying we don't
like those terms they're running to the
government and they're hoping that the
government bails them out now if you
take it a step further whatcha moth
believes Timnath is actually saying let
them fail don't take their [ __ ]
right literally walk away from the
negotiation table if their starting
point is you're not getting equity in my
business for bailout money literally
tell them screw you kick rocks and walk
away why because if you can't get the
terms you need you have to do what every
other investor would do you have to walk
away and when you do that the company
will fail or they will go back to the
traditional equity markets and they'll
actually take the money from private
investors at the terms that they
previously didn't like if the company
fails their H Mothe min a great point on
CNBC do today it's not like every
employee gets fired it goes through an
orderly package bankruptcy and what ends
up happening on that back end of a lot
of these bankruptcies is the employees
actually end up owning more of the
business than they previously did and so
you don't it's like the airplanes
disappear or all of their revenue goes
away or all the employees get fired in
many cases what happens is actually
another team right entrepreneurial team
comes in they buy the assets out of
bankruptcy and because it's a new team
with new ideas innovation competition
etc they actually end up doing better
with the assets over time and that
competition drives a better industry and
also drives a better experience for the
customer right if you don't think that
other teams could take over the airline
business as they and do a better job
than the current executives you're crazy
airlines suck everyone knows they suck
but they suck because there's not free
market competition because there's a lot
of regulation a lot of capital barriers
etc and so allowing this to happen would
actually improve the
industry over a long period of time it
wouldn't get a lot of people fired and
what is likely to happen is that we
wouldn't have to bail them out because
it'll be forced back to go to the
private market for debt and equity
investors so a little bit of a tirade
there but that's a really really
important thing to talk through
so let me I'm gonna try to skip to some
of the more recent questions here and
see what I can but I can get through do
you think China is trying to buy up our
equities a great question I don't
necessarily have an opinion on that what
I do think kind of tangentially related
to this is something to pay a lot of
attention to is the oil market so
there's a lot of price manipulation
obviously going on with Saudi Arabia
Russia etc and they've driven the price
down so far that actually American shale
oil producers are not able to operate at
a break even or at a profit so they're
literally underwater while they're
producing what's happening is that
depression of price with an artificial
depression of the price I've to read a
number of articles now that China and
other places are starting to buy up a
lot of this oil it's cheap right so if
you can store it why not buy it up now
at cheap prices you can always sell it
back into the market at a higher price
or actually use it and so you just got a
more efficient use of your capital and
so I think that's something where you
can watch that happen I'm not sure how
that's playing out equities I haven't
really looked at it so I don't want to
comment there but we do see some of that
stuff happening in in the oil industry
in the oil market so it you know it
could happen but I just haven't got
enough work to actually have an opinion
on that so much background noise is
dinner ready yet dinner is obviously not
ready yet
polenta is cooking though and she says
she's struggling but she's being uh kind
enough to let me kind of hang out here
with you guys wala while she's cooking
some dinner she says hello and to
continue being kind to your friends how
would the government owning Airlines
help people yeah so this is a really
good question in the sense of shouldn't
the government get equity right and
there's always the concern of like is
the government going to nationalize
companies industries or markets I think
that what ends up happening is the
government has to make a choice you
either don't bail out companies or if
you bail them out you get just as good
as terms as a private investor would get
right and obviously if the private
investor and the government get the same
terms most executive teams are going to
to go to the private investor rather
than deal with the government and so
what I think ends up happening is you
basically forced people to not take
government bailout money by financially
incentivizing them not to do it and so I
think that's really how I look at how
this how this goes
joke locusts who helps me with all of
the video stuff is doing a great job he
just texted me and said lol plea and I
hope you didn't break everything so
that's that's great stock buybacks were
or not necessary were banned previously
this is a really important point a lot
of people don't know this but up until
1982 stock buybacks were actually banned
they were illegal they were considered
stock manipulation I think it was in
1982 they were kind of reversed and now
illegal one of the big things meb favor
did a great job on the podcast with me
explaining this but essentially what a
lot of stock buybacks basically are is
their returning value to shareholders so
there's two ways to return values back
to show really three so one is you can
take some of cash and you can literally
issue a dividend you can take that cash
you can buy stocks right so it pushes up
the stock price and all equity holders
benefit from that appreciation in stock
or you can also might sell the company
and then just return kind of the the
proceeds of the sale but those first two
ones are important right because their
returning value to shareholders without
actually selling the business and so the
reason why stock buybacks have become so
popular is because there's actually a
law change where it's become more tax
efficient to do stock buybacks rather
than traditional dividends and therefore
the actual incentive is for the stock
buyback rather than the dividend meb's
idea which i think is pretty smart and
he's definitely much more of an expert
than I am is that we should just change
the tax laws so that a dividend is the
equivalent on a tax basis to a stock
buyback right if you even the playing
field all of a sudden people might not
just buy the stock they might actually
issue the dividends and that would kind
of change the incentive on that
standpoint his other idea which i think
is actually a really good idea is the
whole idea of executive compensation
being tied to spy buybacks is actually a
board of directors and governance issue
so really what should happen is rather
than there be any sort of government
change we should instead start to push
board of directors to not tie executive
compensation to stock price at least in
the short
and therefore you remove the financial
incentive for them to do things like
stock buybacks etc right one of the big
arguments would be rather than continue
to return value to shareholders through
stock buybacks and dividends if instead
you made intelligent investments in R&D
that should actually lead to more
creation of value for shareholders over
long periods of time problem one with
that argument is a lot of executive
teams actually suck at R&D investments
and they end up just burning the cash so
they would have been better off
returning the value to shareholders and
then to is because of the executive
compensation being tied to short-term
price movements of the stock of course
their Center buys to get the stock price
up now
rather than make the long-term
investments to in R&D to drive future
stock price and value so that's kind of
how that plays out let's see here
eventually the dollar drops it will come
but right now dollars are in huge demand
I've got mine in the back pocket and
holding in some trash Bank here yeah so
look for sure at some point the only way
people have to understand think of like
out when you're a kid on the playground
and you know the seesaws right there's
basically a seesaw between dollars and
assets and what I mean by that is when
asset prices go down dollar strengthens
well when the dollar weakens asset
prices go back up right so you get this
kind of opposite effect on those two
assets and so right now dollar
strengthening and asset prices are
dropping but the only way for asset
prices to recover is the dollar will
have to weaken and I think that's what
you know crypto elf is talking about
here great name let's see uh stock
buyback stock buybacks alright I'm gonna
hang out for another ten minutes so get
your questions in pop I work at a hedge
fund in New York City we bring in
speakers to talk to our traders would be
sweet to have you come in we film and
released yeah Kurt go ahead just just
email me or D me on Twitter I'm happy to
to talk about doing it he can find my
you but I'm not gonna give my email out
to to the nine hundred and fifty people
on YouTube who are just gonna send me
crazy stuff is Kevin O'Leary secretly
bullish on Bitcoin outside of the camera
look here's what people have to
understand right any
that you're watching on television this
is like a super super important detail
here's the big secret if you're watching
television it's not news it's
entertainment I don't care what happens
it's entertainment and it's done
specifically to inform the general
public always with an agenda
sometimes that agenda is good sometimes
that agenda is bad but remember what you
are watching it's more marketing than it
is news in many cases and I'll give you
two examples so the first is Larry
Kudlow many of you may know who this is
but Larry Kudlow is like the director of
the National Economic something right
he's supposed to be a big deal and be an
expert Larry Kudlow went on television
right after the first like eight to ten
percent drop and he literally was
telling people on national television
everything's okay
stocks are gonna be fine by the dip
right be TFD by the [ __ ] dip well
what ended up happening is the stock
market fell off a cliff after he said
that he came back on television a couple
of days later I think was Jake Tapper
maybe really pushed him and said wait
are you telling people to buy the dip
and I didn't say buy the dip I said buy
the dip of you're a long-term investor
ah nuanced but pretty big difference
there
and it's because again it's all about a
confidence game as long as everyone has
confidence everything goes up in price
everyone's kind of enjoying the good
times right but the second that there's
a loss of confidence the market rates
which is over and you get the momentum
now pulling against the market and
everyone's shedding assets and they're
looking for dollars and so what ends up
happening is every time you watch
television you remember it's
entertainment it's not necessarily news
and you've got to ask what's the agenda
of the person talking why are they
telling what they're telling me what's
their angle and that's for everyone me
included right everybody that is sharing
information you've got to remember that
so when it comes to Kevin O'Leary look I
actually believe that Kevin O'Leary
understands Bitcoin really well right
everyone seen the video from 2013 I do
believe that he he truly believes what
he's saying which he doesn't believe in
Bitcoin which is fine right it wouldn't
surprise me if he's got a little bit
right he claims to have like a hundred
bucks I bet she's got a little bit more
than that but but I don't think that
he's necessarily misleading people where
he's saying hey Bitcoin sucks and I
don't get it this is stupid
I forbid you from owning a lot of it
like he said to me on CNBC
then he's got you know a couple million
dollars with a Bitcoin and he's secretly
trying to depress the price so you can
buy more I don't think that's what's
happening I actually believe that he
does not think that it has value which
is fine but but again you know obviously
I think that he's wrong on that so I
don't think that people are kind of
being malicious but but always ask the
question as to kind of what people are
doing and why they're telling you what
they're telling you let's see here
what are my thoughts on the real estate
market I live in Las Vegas I'm supposed
to close a new house in two months
should I back out and lose my earnest
money of $4,000 or should I move forward
from Gavin so I'm not gonna comment on
like what you should do but I will talk
a little bit about the real estate
market and here's kind of the way to
look at this so many real estate prices
so forget like publicly traded ETFs and
all that I'm talking about with a
private real estate market so either
buying a home or buying commercial real
estate remember that there is a lack of
reaction or a slow reaction to these
types of situations so again we're only
three to five weeks depending on how you
count into a financial crisis it's not
like you're gonna go talk to people who
are selling their homes before this
crash the people who put up their home
or building for sale in January or
February let's say that they want to
sell for $100,000 if you go to them now
and say hey rules changed your your
buildings actually worth $70,000 or your
homes were seventy thousand dollars
they're gonna tell you shut up you're
wrong my buildings or house is worth a
hundred grand right it's because there
hasn't been enough time for them to
realize that the market has shifted that
prices are coming down etc and so what I
think is we're likely to start to see
that now kind of you know six months six
weeks in eight weeks in you'll start
seeing some people who are a little bit
more forward-thinking and kind of pay
attention more the macro-environment
they'll start to realize that the market
has changed but I don't think you'll
actually see a real impact for three to
six months and part of that is one just
the realization hey the world's changed
we're not in great times we're now in
this recessionary period and therefore
my buildings just not work what it is
worth because the market has changed and
the buyers are not willing to pay what
they were the second thing is the
economics of their building are likely
to change so I own commercial real
estate I have a tenant who's supposed to
be paying me and they're calling me up
and saying I can't pay you I can't pay
you well all of a sudden the value of my
building is dropping
I have a tenant that doesn't pay so I
have no income with the property and so
that's gonna take some time to play out
the longer we go into the crisis the
longer that will or the worse that'll
get for people so I think that you know
real estate will be very attractive over
time I personally will start looking for
real estate both residential and
commercial I'm just not doing it yet I'm
kind of you know very cautiously saying
okay where will I look but again by
three or six months from now I think
that we'll start to see more attractive
prices and that's really kind of we go
see The True Blood in the street you
know and when it comes to real estate
for me the way that I think of real
estate is one of two things either I
want a really really good deal in great
times where I know that I've got a great
tenant and we'll kind of be off to the
races for a long period of time and
we're protected and we can pay off the
property etc or what I want is I want an
absolute fire sale where I'm coming in
and providing liquidity somebody who's
in a liquidity crunch and maybe it's got
no other options right and I think those
are kind of the no-brainer deals to do I
don't see any of those in the market
today I think they will come but again I
think those are kind of three to six
months away at a minimum um
do I think middle seats on airplanes
will go away I do not think that middle
seats are gonna go away but I sure one
wish that they would and two I think
that if we allow these companies to fail
and we get new executive teams
entrepreneurs and I do think that we can
get much better leadership in there
which would be super super beneficial I
think for everybody right look employees
get treated better right shareholders
actually gain more value and customers
get a better experience so it's kind of
a win all the way around all right let's
go I'm gonna do one more question here
or I'll do two more questions all right
so can you talk about your altcoin
diversification and thoughts on high
frequency trading especially in Bitcoin
derivative markets yeah so Josh my
altcoin diversification is non-existent
I owe nothing but Bitcoin right and
people always ask why is that why am I
so kind of strong on that and let me
kind of paint you a much broader picture
so first of all is all of my exposure to
digital assets watching technology comes
this digital age if you will is not just
in liquid cryptocurrencies remember
we've got a entire business around
investing in illiquid investments
meaning that were
buying equity in for-profit private
companies in a venture capital model so
many people know we're investors and you
know figure technologies block by cetera
and so we have exposure to what I
consider more infrastructure or
structural things right some of those
businesses benefit from things other
than Bitcoin right so we've got a number
of businesses that are building on top
of aetherium we've got businesses that
trade in all sorts of all coins etc but
we're investing in the infrastructure so
then when I look at it for me personally
is my exposure professionally is to all
that infrastructure stuff but then what
do I want to hold on the liquid market
personally and the way that I think
about this is is a Venn diagram right on
one side of the Venn diagram or one of
the circles I have what is an attractive
return profile right I think Bitcoin and
a number of other things have an
attractive return profile right so if
Bitcoin goes up in value when we go into
a big bull market in crypto I think
Bitcoin ether a bunch of these assets
will all go up in value right that
because the market cap will expand and
multiple assets will benefit but I think
that also on the other side of the Venn
diagram is a circle where I say what is
the probability that the asset will go
up in value right and so I stack rank
them kind of one two three four five
Bitcoin is head and shoulders above
everything else I've got the moves
confidence that Bitcoin is going to
continue to appreciate and value out of
everything in the cryptocurrency liquid
market and so when I overlay those two
circles Bitcoin is the most attractive
thing to me because I believe it has a
lot of upside and I also believe it has
a high probability of that upside so
kind of it has that asymmetric aspect
but also a high probability of playing
out and so for me the risk I'm willing
to take is I basically want what
overlaps now some people say I don't
care about how probable it is I look at
it more as a venture capital investment
and therefore I actually just want
what's the thing that's the likely to
appreciate the most into the bull market
well it's actually probably not Bitcoin
right and the way that these things work
is look at like stocks for example the
large cap stocks actually have less
volatility than small cap stocks right
so when you have a drawdown what happens
all of those small cap assets all draw
down more than a large cap assets well
in Reverse in the bull market what
happened
large-cap assets appreciate but usually
small-cap assets appreciate even more
same thing happens in crypto right so on
a day where maybe let's say Bitcoin goes
up 10 to 15% ether may go up 25% right
or some other asset may go up 25% but
again I'm not looking for what's going
to perform the best I'm looking for
what's going to deliver enough of an
attractive return overlaid with what has
the highest probability of actually
playing out and so for me that's Bitcoin
other people have other things that are
optimizing for so I think that's really
important to understand kind of why I
don't diversify in the liquid market and
kind of how I how I think about that ok
let's see one more question and then
we're gonna be done here let's see if we
can find a good one my first job out of
college let's see that one let's see let
me see if I can find one more here ok
all right here's a great question what
skills should we come out with post this
lockdown and into a new America so I'm
gonna talk globally right this is really
really important the world has changed
but it's changed in two different
distinct ways one is there is specific
changes around the virus in my opinion
so things like people may not want to
shake hands as much people might be a
little bit shy about going to places
with lots of other people you may see
face masks become more popular array oh
it's like fate fashion face masks etc so
there's what I'll call like virus
specific changes to the world that are
going to kind of play out and the world
will be different specific areas because
of the virus the other thing that's
happening right now is there's an
acceleration of trends that were already
underway but the virus asila is simply
an accelerant so what happens is let's
say for example remote work right
there's a lot of people who had heard of
remote work before they said oh it's
just working from home that's not my
thing every day I go to work I have my
my commute to work I enjoy going into
the office this is great they've never
tried remote work they knew what it was
but never tried it before now all of a
sudden the government mandates remote
work right everyone go home stay at home
and so now they for a couple of weeks
got a try remote work I think that we
will see on a market share basis like
remote work non remote work remote work
just got more market share right more
people will now do remote work simply
because there was an acceleration of the
trend just because people tried it right
and they enjoy they think that it's easy
right I saw today
she'll mow not who runs a FinTech fund
and it's just a generally a great person
he tweeted and said that he talked to
the founder of a very large finance
company a fin tech company and they were
saying that they've been working remote
it's going very well and they're
actually considering post virus not
going back and getting an office lease
and what they believe they could do is
save them about ten million dollars a
year by not having to pay rent or buy
snacks and do all that kind of stuff so
again there's plenty of companies are
becoming remote but how long would it
are thinking that company to go remote
it probably never would have gone remote
but now they try it out with the viruses
you get an acceleration of that trend
another one is digital learning right
kind of I had this tweet I think earlier
in the week where I basically said look
the the the sham is up in colleges right
there's a lot of colleges that now are
being revealed to simply be asset
management firms that have a school and
what I mean by that is you know
Stanford's got like a thirty billion
dollar endowment and then they've got
the school
well that endowment is supposed to be
like for a rainy day to invest in the
school to protect them to do all these
things and they have a very tax
advantageous status by being an
endowment tied to a school it's very
similar to a religion etc right and kind
of the way that they manage their money
but what all of a sudden we had a rainy
day kids aren't going to the school what
you see is not the endowment stepping in
and saying you know what we're gonna pay
for the salary of all the cafeteria
workers the janitorial staff we're gonna
make sure that all of our students have
the capital they need we're gonna make
sure that the professors and the staff
are all paid instead what happens is
they start to do hiring freezes they do
no bonuses some
schools are actually laying off or
cutting ties with vendors that then
caused layoffs etc and so I think that
people are just realizing wait a second
why do you have thirty billion dollars
or ten billion dollars or a billion
dollars if on the rainy day you don't
use it right that kind of doesn't make
sense and so I think that we'll kind of
see that trend of online learning
because now students are rising wait a
second I'm sitting at home I'm on zoom I
just attended my class why don't I have
to go pay room and board why am I paying
$50,000 a year and taking on all this
debt to do this so I can I think that's
another trend um that will come out of
it so long story short is the virus will
be an accelerant for a lot of trends the
virus will cause some virus specific
changes in the world but the specific
question here is what skills can you
come out with right and the way that I
bucket this is two things one is I'm a
big fan of what a Paul Graham calls
learning to unlearn he wrote this
fantastic blog post I highly suggest you
guys go read it Paul Graham is the
founder of Y Combinator no but basically
what he talks about is in school you are
taught to learn the answers for the test
right you're literally taught if I go to
class I read the book I listen to the
notes there's gonna be a test if I get
the right answers on the test I did a
good job but then when you go to the
next class you forget what you were
supposed to learn in the last class
right you're almost you're only learning
so that you can pass the test and an
example he uses is like I think he says
like you know French Revolution
literature or something if you want to
learn about the French Revolution
literature what you would do is you
would just go read the five best books
on French Revolution literature you
would consume that content you would
know it because you read the best
content and then you would be able to
move on because you learn that
information instead because we have a
test based education system is you don't
actually read the best books what you do
is you read the teachers material
because that's what's gonna be on the
test and so whether that's the best
information or not you're just simply
being trained to pass the test and what
he sees as he sees founders who come to
them at Y Combinator and they say hey I
want to pass the test right what's the
playbook so that I can raise money
what's the answer to the test so I can
sell my company and what he says is you
have to learn to unlearn that stuff
there is no exact test you have to learn
problem-solving you have to learn
critical thinking skills you can't just
simply study for a test because life
doesn't have it a specific test there's
not a quarterly
for an end-of-year test and so I think
that's like one big skill set how you do
that
is really hard I think one of the best
ways to do that is just reading a lot of
really really diverse content right go
and find the great thinkers from history
and some of the current thinkers today
and just consume content from them learn
how they actually use mental models
learn how they do frameworks because I
think that you'll you'll be able to
unlearn what you've learned in school
and learn this new way of thinking that
can be very advantageous for you so
that's bucket one is learn to unlearn
the second bucket I think is what I call
the digital skill set and the digital
skill set really is one big bucket that
includes everything that you need for a
digital economy so can you write online
you should be able to do that can you
use social media to distribute
information you should be able to do
that can you learn how to communicate
with other people all around the world
on all these different platforms you
should learn how to do that can you
produce content like videos and music
exciting you know audio etc you should
learn some of those skills can you
actually be able to run a business
online so can you sell things online can
you build products online can you do all
of these things that all goes into the
digital skill set and each one of those
is actually really complex so don't try
to learn it all at once instead just
pick something say hey you know what I
want to learn how to better use social
media go figure out who's doing it well
reach out to them and say hey I know
nothing about this I know something else
they're right a great way to kind of
approach somebody like me or others is
to say to look I know nothing about how
to use social media I know nothing about
how to create content I know nothing
about how to sell things online but I
went to school as a chemist and I've
been doing this thing that I think is
really interesting and I've got a whole
bunch of information I could share with
you that I've written up and that
information will get you up to speed and
give you you know chemistry 101 and if
you read these three pages I wrote
you'll have about 25% of the knowledge I
have I spent four years learning it but
you can learn it in you know two hours
I'm willing to true lead you I'll teach
you a little bit about chemistry if
you'll teach me how to sell things
online or create content or write better
or whatever now all of a sudden what
you're doing is you're giving value
while also asking for value right those
types of people tend to get better
responses over a long period of time
than people who just simply say hey
I don't know anything about this will
you teach me and so I think developing
that digital skillset is gonna be really
really important so if you think of it
it's kind of a stack you've got to learn
how to think the right way for the world
to learn how to unlearn what you learned
in school and learning critical thinking
skills and mental frameworks and then
actually learn how to be productive in a
digital economy right how do you create
value products services etc and do it at
scale with the tools available on the
Internet and so I think that all of this
is kind of a lifelong learning journey
but if you can come out of this
quarantine with one or two skills that
you didn't have before you went in I
think that you can kind of look back and
say hey quarantine was a positive
development for me I learned a lot and
I'm kind of in a better position the
second thing that I will say kind of
along these lines is if you have lost
your job which there's definitely you
know a thousand people watching this
right now there's definitely somebody on
here who's lost their job do not be
afraid to switch careers you basically
have been put in a position where you
were down one career path you now have
been put back to kind of the restart
button you can continue down that same
path right let's say that you're a
worker at a restaurant or you work in
the service industry hospitality travel
all these different industries if you're
going down that path now you have to
have a chase oh wait timeout I lost my
job do I want to continue in this
industry or do I want to do I want to go
down a different path right use this as
an opportunity rather than a setback and
if you do that the right way what you
can do is you can retrain your skills
right you can go and you can get trained
as a computer scientist you can learn
other skill sets you can get trained in
marketing etc there's a whole bunch of
resources out there I just interviewed
Ruben Harris on the podcast you know
it's coming called career Karma
basically you go into an app you tell
them here's my goal here's my current
background here's my current skillset
and they'll point you to the right
resource to help you get trained so
they'll tell you hey you want to learn a
computer engineering great here's the
three schools that we think that you
should go to that are online boot camps
etc oh you want to learn marketing vote
here etc so there's resources out there
I highly suggest you guys put those
things to work I'm gonna go eat dinner
Polina made chicken wings which if
anybody's been watching lunch money you
know that there is a surplus of chicken
wings in the world right now because the
cancellation of NCAA
March Madness and so if you want some
chicken wings there are tons of chicken
wings out in the world that are at a
reduced price right now and they can be
frozen so go pick yourself up some
chicken wings and I think that you can
get some nice food plan is an excellent
cook I'm a lucky man
so if you guys can please I've been told
like this video subscribe to the channel
go ahead and hit the alarm thinks you
get notifications take the URL tweet it
out do whatever you can so that more
people can watch this stuff I really
appreciate you guys all tuning in for an
hour I did not expect to go that long
but I was just you know enjoying talking
about this stuff and I will try to do
these more often and I will see you guys
sometime next week probably so have a
great night
have a great weekend stay safe stay
alert be kind to people and we'll talk
soon